this is just that to me like this this is
like the most up and down relationship yeah
like that is what it's like with
having Henry Cavill is Superman
[Music] what is happening there citizens
of the reject Nation we have some major DC
updates here that are coming from The Hollywood
Reporter something a little bit more reliable
than your average scooper out there ladies
and gentlemen leave a like because that's
just always a nice thing to do we need nice
things in this world John who are you I'm
good sir how are you good you rush to get your
Batman shirt how was that going it's so good I
love this Batman once I said we're doing DC Video
I'm running to my car to get my Batman shirt yeah
all right man on top of it here's the nuts and
bolts version of what's going on right now I'm
gonna quote Jeff Snyder here who's becoming
a popular scooper himself but this is pretty
much the nuts and bolts version Wonder Woman
3 is dead that's right Gal Gadot passed away
terrible things are happening can't even get
Linda Carter yeah the basic version of it is
that they probably turn into a treatment for
this uh movie that you know Patty Jenkins was
hard at work but it doesn't quite line up with
what they have in store for the future of the
DCU I find that kind of a bummer because Wonder
Woman I think is a amazing film and while wasn't
a fan of 84 I really felt like it still deserved
a part three and for them to go out on a high note
doesn't mean it's I don't know if it's a little
misleading to say it's dead but the impression
of this article that I quickly read through
the current possible plan because James Gunn
is supposed to present like a whole thing with
him and saffron present a whole thing to David
zasloff of what the plan is so nothing's like
concrete at the moment it sounds like they want
to just essentially do a big reset on the entire
thing but keep this Suicide Squad 52 but yes I
want my movie still around yeah that's not in the
article John how do you feel about Wonder Woman
three possibly being dead I mean it's like it
is yeah it's absolutely a bum myrrh because that
is like one of their more reliable even though
84 wasn't well received it's one of their more
Flagship characters one that most people agree on
at least in terms of the casting and a lot of the
portrayal thus far I don't know I mean if they're
truly resetting that's a pretty big bummer at the
same time I get them wanting to reset I just
feel like it'll be hard for people to swallow
if it's not Gal Gadot some way don't worry we
got Black Adam and Superman used to get to Boom
Black Adam sequel looking unlikely apparently so
there's been a lot of debate here about whether
or not Black Adam was a success or was it a big
box office bomb I expected it to break even is
it even gonna do that there's been reports that
it's certainly a bomb but then Dwayne Johnson
he came out uh four hours ago up from recording
this video I wanted to confirm with financiers
before I share this excellent Black Adam news
with your films we'll profit between 52 to 72
million fact at almost 400 million worldwide
we are building our new franchise step by step
first Captain America did 370 million for the
DC future I don't know the exact intention of
Dwayne Johnson doing this maybe to shut down all
those things that are saying that's going to flop
or maybe it is having something to do with the
fact that he's worried that he might not get the
future films like guys it's actually did all right
because don't forget cap the first Captain America
so come on to push it along a little further
yes they need to spend more money on it next
time I wouldn't be surprised if they don't get
a sequel because I mean 52 to 72 Millions like
that's a that's a good amount of money to make
but they didn't spend a lot of money to try to
get that 52 to 72 million they only made enough
to make a mid budget indie film they need that
Blockbuster profit because one of the second one
cost more money theoretically let's mix Black
Adam 2 a very introspective one location movie
yeah and he was talking about doing a Hawkman
spin-off but I don't know that if they're gonna
be a Black Adam too I mean I don't think we get
a Hawkman spin-off here's the big one here's the
kicker after all that stuff about Henry Cavill
coming back into the the fold to play Superman
Man of Steel Henry Cavill himself even going
on Instagram saying I am back to Superman he's
doing his best Dwayne Johnson impression it's
being reported now because it looks like what
they're trying to do is do as much of a reason
that means even putting the Snyder verse to rest
and so you know they've they filmed the Cameo as
Superman for the flash but it's still up in
the air whether or not they want to actually
include it depending on the plan that they
set forward for the future of the DC Universe
this is just that to me like this this is
like the most up and down relationship yeah
like that is what it's like with having Henry
Cavill is Superman yeah it's well that and it's
too it's like living in a house where like your
parents are constantly like almost about to make
it work and get back together or something too
because now it's like no no no we bought it we
brought in James gun we got we got Peter
saffron it's gonna be great it's gonna be
great except we're also giving them like a
whole train wreck of a Segway that I can't
imagine is gonna rub everybody the right
way it just seems like nobody is getting
the full kind of I don't know conscientious
treatment here well I think if they want to
move forward they have to have a fresh start but
keep the suicide squad alive that's right Squad
they still haven't even presented their entire
plan yet and I imagine they'd want to preserve
some of this like I don't I I don't feel like
you can just confidently go ahead and come do
a complete reset I think that is not a way of
listening to the fans ultimately you know yeah
but if it is what's best for the long term
maybe perhaps like I at this point why not
try everything out DC just just do it all cancel
it all then bring it all back later yeah you can
always ignore whatever you do now and come back
to the Snyder verse later I don't care anymore
just make it happen the next order of business
Aquaman 2 might be the last time we see Jason
Momoa playing Arthur Curry Aquaman himself but as
we saw like Jason Mo not long ago doing a video
like I got some exciting [__] to announce
to you guys but I can't say that what it is
whatever he said in that video a lot of people are
speculating and it seems like it would be likely
based off of what his enthusiasm was is that he
would he's being eyed to possibly play Lobo which
is a character he he's the perfect guy and he's a
man massive fan of that character strangely enough
as much as I really like him as Aquaman I'm also
like out of all the news strangely on board for
that one all these random train wrecks but then
the perfect dream casting all right it aren't
you happy it's not Michael Bay slope yeah even
though Aquaman one made a billion dollars it's
just a little bit uh strange to me that out of
all the news that's the one that I'm like yeah
I'm on board with that that's fine we had enough
Aquaman and then you know Batman's still gonna
persevere but you still got Shazam for you the
Gods coming out you still got Blue Beetle you
still got the Flash movie releasing it's like
at this point you're like if you're just gonna
erase it all what's the point of even releasing
them yeah I was just gonna confuse people that
much more at least the general populace who's
not following this news very closely but yeah
as of this report it's like Henry Cavill not
coming back again basically Wonder Woman three
dead all that stuff you were just excited about
not anymore and um I I just I don't know anymore
I I don't know at this point I'm like before
before we get up in arms about every little
thing I was like let's just wait to see what
James could actually believe what's presented
yeah first like the one that seems most likely
to me is what happened Wonder Woman three but
everything else is kind of speculation and scoop
talking and everything it's all true it's all true
let's just believe it all let's believe it all
I'll believe nothing until I see the movie on
the screen alrighty well there we are guys what do
you think which person is here's the the elicited
the biggest reaction out of you all uh leave your
thoughts down below I'm just exhausted I'm sorry
all the DC fans just need a hug this is supposed
to be like the biggest thing ever now it's like
ah Christ I don't know what to believe so let's
just wait for official stuff I suppose alrighty
Everett pixel might Baker Everett we
might not know anything about you I
don't know anything about you we can make it
up you can you can we can project onto you
everything you've been a patron of ours for
four years that's incredible I don't really
know much about it you are dedicated and unlike
the DC Universe you've been a constant that's
around your life you have to worry about you
being recast we don't have to worry about
you coming and going whether or not Everett's
going to stay or leave Everett is the picture
of consistency I think what James Gunn needs to
do moving forward Everett is take a page out of
every pixel my bakery what can we learn from
every pixel my Baker As we move forward with
the DC Universe we Comfort people with the warm
embrace of consistent and jovial caring love so
thank you Everett for always being a monthly
Christmas present to us and I hope you have an
amazing amazing 2023 filled with laughter love
and lots of play time with men and women [Music]